candace what's going on how can i help a
few weeks ago
i found out about my husband's porn
addiction
that he's been keeping a secret for our
entire relationship
how long have you all been together um
married for three together for six okay
um he has been addicted since he was
12. okay um and i just want to know
how to establish trust going forward
and how to help him overcome this
addiction
so one i'm sorry that you just
discovered this how did you figure it
out how did you discover it
um i actually had a dream about it and
i confronted him about my dream and he
was like what the heck
and came clean about everything
yeah because he realized oh god i'm
married to a sorcerer this is not going
to end well for me right
um so if you had a dream and you just
thought well i think my husband's
got some addiction challenges and then
you just asked him about it and he's
like
oh busted i didn't believe the dream
like i thought it was just a random
dream but i was like hey i had this
dream
it's kind of weird and then he yeah
wow it came true so how'd that how'd the
conversation go tell me about how that
conversation went
um he at first
kind of like
made it seem like it wasn't as much of a
big deal like
he was kind of denying it at first but
then he eventually
um just started i don't know
it's i
let's see because he he was like asleep
and then he woke up and he was kind of
groggy and then he
he finally started telling me like
yeah this yeah i've been watching porn
like for a long time and he made it
sound like
it was like every like few months
but then he actually said it's more like
weekly so
um tell me what was going on in your
heart
were you just devastated did you kind of
know already or was it did it answer a
lot of questions for you was it weird
were you more annoyed that he's been
keeping secrets from you what
was what's going on in your in your soul
like all of the above like at first i
was
completely shocked i had no idea
um i thought we were like
the couple that never had to deal with
that type of thing
that was shock and hurt um
but as he started telling me more and
more i also
felt empathy towards him because he's
been keeping it a secret for so long and
he doesn't want to be doing this yeah
and he doesn't know how to
get out of it you know yeah so
here's the the good news and the bad
news the bad news is you can't
make him do anything
he's gonna have to decide that he wants
to change whatever behavior it is
um anytime we i talk to folks about
addictive behaviors
um
i always want to make sure we're talking
about it at a 30 000 foot view
and so addiction is addiction as
addiction and some people
use pornography and sleep around some
people use heroin and some people work
90 hours a week
and some people are addicted to being
right addicted to power
and bossing people around addiction is
addiction is addiction and the chemicals
involved are very similar and for some
folks
um pornography is not that big of a deal
for other folks it's
devastating in their soul and so he who
he
is married to which is you right you all
gonna have to sit down and have an
honest not groggy conversation not a
hem-holly conversation
but a direct conversation about how this
particular behavior makes you feel
and you're gonna have to have a specific
conversation about
what the violation feels like and you're
gonna have to do some work on your own
to decide to
kind of divvy up here is it the secrets
that broke your heart
is it the fact that he's been struggling
with something for six years and he's
kept that from you
or is it the actual he is
looking at naked people and he is
thinking about other people that are not
me right and it's probably like you said
it's it's a mixture of all of that what
i'll tell you is
it's been my experience that the deepest
pain underneath all those layers is the
deception
and the fact that you weren't worthy
enough to be trusted with a hurt he had
especially for that long right that's
hard
um is that overcomeable for sure
one thousand million percent yes okay
um what you're gonna have to do is be
honest with him
about your feelings and even if it's not
all parsed out at the beginning if it's
a jumbled mess
um still sit down and be honest with him
and you may have already done this if
you haven't
please take the time to write out how
you feel get all those feelings down so
that there
you can see them laid out they're in an
order and then i want you to draw your
boundaries pretty firmly
here's what i won't accept in my house
here's what i won't tolerate in the
house
um and here's who i expect the man that
i'm married to be
and then he's gonna have to make some
decisions and um
this can be a challenging thing and this
can be a not challenging thing this
could be just some hard decisions he's
got to make
and then you're all going to work
together and then this is just going to
be a story this is just going to be a
footnote in the history of your
relationship moving forward and so i
don't want to undermine it and i don't
want to over sensationalize it i want to
get right direct in the middle of it and
deal with it directly does that make
sense
yeah it does what i'll tell you is
tiptoeing around
holding him hostage with you right
um addiction at the end of the day is a
connection disorder right it is
people trying to fill voids
relational voids with stuff with things
with other chemical processes that are
cheap chemical substitutes for the
chemicals we get when we are connected
with other people
and so when folks use harsh
uh use they weaponize certain things man
it just makes things worse
and so all that to say is be vulnerable
with him
be clear with him set really firm
boundaries with him
love him he's your husband love him
walk alongside him but you can't do the
work for him he's gonna have to make
some hard decisions
by the way here's what some hard
decisions might look like
that he doesn't have a computer in the
house that he's got to go through you
for the netflix login that
um he has there you know there's a
number of web filters that will
send you everything that he goes to and
looks at et cetera et cetera et cetera
that you've got unfettered access to his
phone it's going to depend on how
serious he is about taking care of
himself okay and
keeping your relationship in a good
healthy place
um and then you may as part of this
vulnerability conversation
he may talk to you about some things
that he struggled with you over the last
six or seven years
and y'all will have to be able to hear
that and heal your relationship from the
floor up right
and so this is a 360 degree conversation
moving forward but all you can control
is you
you can't do the hard work for him and
but i do want you to keep the light on
in this relationship man because there's
a lot of hope at the end of this thing
okay okay so you've known him for six
years
do you believe him that he wants to stay
married that he wants to
have a whole relationship a whole
connection with you that he wants to be
plugged in
and make this thing work i do
yeah he is committed to seeing a
counselor
and figuring out like how deep this goes
yeah so there's there's the spelunking
expeditions there's the seeing how deep
it goes and then there's the really
um there's the simple
behavior stuff right we need some
strategies pretty quick
right like if he was an alcoholic we
wouldn't have alcohol in the house and
you would commit to not drinking around
him and when friends came over you'd let
him know hey guys don't bring beer over
the house don't bring whiskey over the
house because
um because husband's getting clean right
or if he was
addicted to working too much or addicted
to being busy all the time
you'd set some pretty you all too would
co-create some boundaries together
on when at six o'clock i'm coming home
no matter what
and if i lose my job i lose my job but
i'm gonna start learning how to invest
in my family learn how to be at home
and so this is similar to that there's
some deep stuff you got to get to the
roots and all that stuff
but there's also some just behavioral
issues that y'all can address right away
together
and if it helps to go to the therapist
with them go to counselor with them and
y'all learn some new strategies together
that would be awesome
that'd be good um do you want to stay
married to this dude
i do yeah are you sure committed
yes okay because i hear there's just
something
there's a i'm trying to think what it is
there's a sense of resignation in your
voice it may just because you're nervous
because you're on the radio but there's
a sense of resignation in your voice
um if he's in
and you're in i want you to be all fully
in
okay someone who's a true addict
knows when somebody's not being fully
present with them and that's what you go
chasing
that full presence okay okay
do you feel good about that yeah
i do yeah okay good so tonight uh maybe
not tonight tonight i want you to take
time writing this letter
uh writing out here's all of my feelings
on this
and a couple again a couple of places to
start i've already mentioned this
is just the sexual ethic violation if
this violated
a commitment you all had with one
another man call that out
um if this you're hurt because he kept
he was hurting for six years and he kept
that a secret from you
man call that out if you are devastated
by the secrecy
and the deception and the lying call
that out
you sh all those all those things should
be right
um and if there's more to it than that
put everything
out in an orderly way let him know how
you feel not in a shameful way but in an
honest direct way
that's you being vulnerable and hear him
as he responds as he
as he um gives it back to you and i've
got high hopes for your relationship i
want you to let me know how that
conversation goes with him
um and again if both of y'all are all in
you all have a bright future together
candace
and we'll be thinking about y'all